in this video today we will be
showcasing the fight scene of godzilla
and kong in the ocean
the one shown in various scenes of the
trailer and a teaser clips
and we have arranged them in ascending
order so yeah spoiler alert
major spoiler alert in fact you have
been worn
and i'm sure there is more to the fight
than what we will be showing you right
now
and this will just hype you up even more
for the upcoming movie
so when you have seen the movie do
remember to tune back into this video
and tell us if we were right or not
so let's do this so firstly we have the
admiral of the fleet looking a bit shook
up and realizing that the king of the
monsters is approaching their convoy
that is carrying kong we know this for
sure because of the laid back attitude
of the person behind him
then we see the fighter jets being
scrambled to deter the big g and shoot
missiles at him
in a futile attempt to make him change
goes when that fails
the ship which include the older
battleships with the big guns are
directed to throw in all their armament
towards the titan approaching them
but he dives inside the water to avoid
being further irritated
so then the scene commences with
godzilla resurfacing and ramming against
the battleship that was shooting at him
here we see how durable titan's skin is
against metal and alloy
the scenes makes the warship look like a
paper boat and does nothing to deter the
g-man
from its course of action then we see
the december clip of kong roaring
the next part is the scene of godzilla
destroying the fighter jets with his
tail
this shows how aware godzilla is with
using his flexible tail
then comes the scene where godzilla is
swimming between the wreckage as
we can still see the oil tanker ship
that carries kong
being still afloat now comes the part
where kong
is looking down at the water beneath the
ship anticipating a move by godzilla
and also not backing down since he bows
to no one which is rightly so
now suddenly the big j comes up and
using his back
and his hand he flips the ship upside
down and in the process
kong who is still under chains connected
to the ship desperately tries
to not fall into the water and tries to
get back up but to no avail
and this looks like he is going to drown
then the december
scene of godzilla underwater swimming
against something
connects as we said before there will be
more to this fight than just this
kong somehow manages to get back up and
destroy the shackles he is bind to
in order to face godzilla he jumps from
one ship to another like freaking super
mario
and then lands on the aircraft carrier
making the big stand
and taunting godzilla to come over and
fight so we also see the human
characters react
strongly and being afraid of what is
going to happen since they are all in
the same boat
kong free from his chains still knows
that he is against all odds in this
battle
now the scene from the first trailer
comes as we can see godzilla climbing up
on top of the aircraft carrier
being super pissed and ready to end the
apes life he comes up and in the process
destroys the fighter jets
and heavily damaging the ship's hull
here in the scene we can see
the sharp teeth of godzilla being a
little bit different than the earlier
ones
and we can also see his gills but this
doesn't look like an easy fight as kong
was already charging up for
a superman punch that connects right to
on the left cheek of the nuclear lizard
godzilla however with his weight and
tail as counter balance does not fall
down
but retaliates with that famous [ __ ]
slap to an unsuspecting kong
which makes the giant ape fall but first
on the ship
godzilla who isn't expecting a fast
comeback is then pushed into the water
by comb
and this scene connects with the other
ships firing depth charges against
godzilla
who in turns maneuvers himself below the
aircraft carrier and charges up to shoot
his atomic breath
right from underneath the ship and fully
destroying it but with kong jumping to
avoid
being hurt by the blast then we end with
a scene of the atomic breath reaching to
the clouds
and so with that we come to the end of
the video do like
for support and smash that subscribe
button
and also slap slap slap that
notification bell for regular updates
till the next video take care fam